all right so another month another
journal entry might god that's a lot of
white behind are hella little better
alright so another month another journal
entry this one is in fact for June I'll
just let the video speak for itself but
once again
thank you all for watching this I make
it for you maniacs who are actually like
I want to see more than just movie
reviews I want to see his life thank you
I need a dog to transition gypsy you're
a gypsy you can't always look sad
otherwise people will start to think
you're sad it's the first of June and to
start the month off we're going hiking
but it's early in the morning danger and
Ramsey kept me up all night
so yeah let's let's get our health phone
app away so uh we're going to mount side
to I get so Google Maps was like oh I'll
taking them outside not the trail to
hike it look the place so yeah it's like
17 minutes out of the way [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] you know it's funny I say [ __ ]
a lot in these vlogs because they were
think it's the first time I say it but I
do it in like every entry so yeah when
people ask what are you doing the
Northwest we walk in the woods that's
just what we do so I look exhausted it's
only because we're doing maps I and I am
exhausted
vanessa was like how many do maps I you
want to go is like pretty sure I should
work up to that and then we get here in
the Pathfinder over here's like let's go
and so I just about throw up about 7
minutes and really slow people that I
was really super thankful for because
they kept normal pace I have long legs
and I'm [ __ ] beat and now we're one
quarter of the way through we're having
fun no no be good please this is gonna
be the predator shot where it's gonna go
I'm at the top of mount side got my
mount side badge
Vanessa and I both did know that I get a
badge just accomplishment in pain but
also accomplishment and I hurt mount
side one day later
my legs hurt a lot dishwashers going
that's the sound you hear
well vanessa has it on good authority
that Kim Chi it's really good but it
looks like brains smells horrendous and
I don't want to touch it so Vanessa this
is use you as like the guinea pig so
Dark Phoenix screening tonight which is
funny because there just got an email
reminder that just like remember this is
just for press and their Plus Ones so
there's no usually the people can come
to it and get tickets through other
means none of that for Dark Phoenix and
there's this hardcore like highlighted
reminder like no check-ins is basically
until the embargo lifts which is
tomorrow night it's these are all kind
of red flags it doesn't look good for
Dark Phoenix so it just got back from
Dark Phoenix and I was gonna say a you I
won't remember it in t-minus one day but
I'm really trying to find anything I
like about it and I just can't like it's
not as good as any of the x-men movies
any of the other ones it might be talk
[ __ ] we'll see when I'm filming whatever
I say I say but oh so there's a super
tight lipped embargo for Dark Phoenix I
can't get that review up until tomorrow
night 10:00 p.m. but I just saw the last
episode of Chernobyl so that review is
happening gonna review it either way but
still
[Music]
it's a car wash you know what those are
lightly irradiated bills fancy stuff for
a city cop you have helped Vanessa who's
the goodness here's a good news a Dark
Phoenix reviews going out at 10:00 I'm
really tired
trash so I get to sleep through the bus
fire the comments section so this is
what happened last night it's funny it
looks thinking there's a therapy session
usually when I filled in my cards post
therapy but not this time I'm just at
the store but here's last night so I do
my review I put up my review of Dark
Phoenix and at a part in that review I
rattle off all the x-men movies that are
better than Dark Phoenix which is all of
them
but I forgot the Wolverine and a lot of
people were coming a little bit
Wolverine yeah
and so a few people commented like
Deadpool 1 and 2 and so I was like
alright I'll just make a comment correct
it and then pin it at the top so I made
a comment like yes this movie is also
worse than the Wolverine and Deadpool 1
and 2 and my last dentist appointment
and now instead of being inundated with
people like me like what about this
movie and what about these movies I'm
now inundated with comments of people
who think I'm calling Deadpool [ __ ] I
guess which it's funny because if you
want to verify that if anyone wants to
verify that I do have a review of it you
just check that out to test the
hypothesis to cross-reference so instead
of being in the no.1 situation that oh I
totally forgot this movie I'm now in the
no.1 situation that people are
misunderstanding to comment so I just
deleted it point of this is for everyone
to know that the Internet is a no-win
situation
wrapped in a Kobayashi Maru wedged
between a rock and a hard place and all
you can really do is be cool with the
fact that once again you didn't quite
stick the landing 100% you got to be
good with at max on your best day 98
so that's that that's my internet lesson
for today so there's just released a
poster for Wonder Woman 1984 that has
this thor ragnarok ish visual appeal to
it so I'm gonna post it on Instagram
with a joke pointing to that watch the
world ice why don't watch Star Trek
discoveries I don't even know what I'm
saying
but I just thought of an awesome Star
Trek storyline and let me know if this
has actually happened we're like this
person realizes that every time he gets
transported he essentially dies and his
consciousness goes to the other place
and there's the molecules come together
and form a new body so he's not actually
himself like think Alan Moore's Swamp
Thing but just like with a person with a
person body nose swamp body and yes
that's what badger was talking about in
Breaking Bad that one time but my
friends and I had talked about this
concept at nauseam before that episode
aired so anyhow just imagine this
character who's like am I even myself am
i human what is I'm I am outside the
rules of humanity because I'm not
actually myself I died and so I'm not
even the person I grew up as I'm just
the aggregate of the memories of that
person and then this person just snaps
and wants to wipe out Starfleet and all
their technology but I'm letting him do
so that would just take humanity back
centuries because we wouldn't have the
technology and we'd be fighting over
territory again because all the
Roddenberry vision is it's dawn now this
this this peaceful world that humanity
strive for wouldn't it be a great
villain I am NOT stoned right now so my
friend Nathan is coming over we're
hanging out for either a late lunch or
early dinner however you want to see it
and as you know me I like dressed a nice
funny thing is so does he so we'll dress
up and vests and ties and I know we just
hang out with his life's too short to
not dress nice and enjoy dressing nice
just cuz today is actually a very
special day it's the one-year
anniversary should I call it an
anniversary I'm not sure but basically
it's been one year since I cancelled my
Twitter account and deleted it and yes
life is better without it
I just don't think Twitter is conducive
to real conversations like most of the
things you see on Twitter all the
Twitter beefs and whatnot could have
just been a private conversation that
happened but no now gonna get those
likes and retweets for it so right there
that just skews the motivation to even
talk to somebody the fact that
conversations at all are happening on
Twitter and call out outrage all that
stuff is happening on Twitter I can't
help but see the motivation to be like
oh it's happening here because likes and
retweets and that's that's that has
monetary value because the people say
and so it just it skews the motivation
and the purity of a conversation which
conversations don't really happen it's
just everything is cannon fodder for
that and I just I don't think it's how
people have grown adapted and evolved to
interact it's so change so very abruptly
and so quickly dad um really anyone on
there I don't think they're the happiest
versions of themselves so I encourage
anyone to delete it most of you won't
those are my two cents as someone who
did delete it and is happier I'm saying
it's best to delete it so we're going to
breakfast at this restaurant that diners
drive-ins and dives came to so there's
one thing I can do is put my sunglasses
or Vanessa's sunglasses on the back of
my head and I'm gonna walk in there we
like this davon Triple D we're going to
flavor do you realize I'm doing that for
Christmas for your Christmas I meant to
take a picture but now we're doing a
video of the three ways you could say
this it's helped people make friends
have fun or it's helped people make
friends have fun oh
or help people make friends have fun
it's I'm confused
alright so here's the thing is on sale
for 30 bucks and I mean I'll get after
30 bucks find some enjoyment out of it
just to have for an aesthetic reason
just for aesthetic purposes I could just
have it with the NES and SNES classic
it'll be just kind of like a cool calm
pledge and have it with the Genesis mini
that's coming out so you just have four
of these they should totally do an n64
classic because that would make complete
and total sense
but yeah I'm still for $30 I'll get this
how is this not begging for a pillow
fight to happen
all right I've won - you look nervous is
it this - I don't know how I got it so I
had a wife beautiful like you
who tells me I worry too much who tells
me I got a smile more who gambles and
gets deep with the sharks hey what a day
take our fur face we have enough money
for surgery she can't take it I just
want to see her smile again I just want
her to know that I don't care about the
scars so I put a razor in my mouth and
do this to myself you know what she
can't stand the sight of me now I'm
always smiling alright so I didn't know
this is how it works so Vanessa's
windshield has a crack I didn't know
this is like magic but if you if you
press on the crack it like cracks more
witchcraft like I don't know how you
want to take this just take it as truth
ordering something on Amazon to replace
something you lost is simply you're not
ordering something you are but you're
essentially you're paying a finder's tax
you're paying money to ensure that
Ramsey Jim point is you're paying money
to ensure that you find the thing you
lost because once your replacement
arrived
you'll find it again so now you'll have
to case in point this ps3 chord lost it
ordered it came today plugged it into my
ps3 found the one I lost
so when movies come out there's an
embargo so when reviewers watch it they
can't review it they can't put the
review up until that embargoes up so
usually it's you know it goes 6 a.m. the
day after you screen the movie the
embargo is up you can I'll talk about it
so what we've generally we reviewer folk
deal on YouTube is we watch it review it
upload the review and just schedule it
to go live with an embargo lifts which
means everyone can some conspiracy
theories about all of us working
together to drop out of these at the
exact same time the truth is much less
interesting just when the embargo lifted
why do they look so angry like they want
to kill me so I've been editing it it's
5:45 in the morning I've been editing my
Toy Story 4 review all night and now
it's 15 minutes before the embargo lifts
so says one email says 6 a.m. the
screening invite I got for LA says 9
a.m. Pacific so I'm gonna go with the 6
a.m. and we'll see what happens so in my
Toy Story 4 review because I exported it
it was a thing in the beginning I didn't
like so I redid it and you know you
slide the the timeline around and I
didn't think this happened because it
was later in the video but I overlapped
the video so there's one part about
three and a half minutes in which it's
like a couple seconds of me behind me
talking and there's me in front there's
two of me on straight at the same time
someone said Noob Saibot confirmed point
is is what happens sometimes when you
stay up until 5 a.m.
editing your videos but that's just how
I do it there's not always a [ __ ]
there's usually no fuck-ups even when I
stay up till 5 a.m. but I'm really tired
wow that's dark I should have left it as
dark cuz it's a dark day alright so
yesterday I saw that hot toys have a
scarlet spider coming out
I'm super jacked for it and I checked I
kept checking to them like nothing's
gonna go in pre-order and then it did I
guess and now you have to be on a
waitlist and so I tried to go in the
waitlist it's like you have to update
your password and tried to update my
password and I haven't got an email baby
basically I'm just I'm just sad just
doing some farming get that eggs fake so
this is a vlog worthy morning something
for the fact that Russia has Twitter now
that's that's weird it's only a matter
of time before he slips and tells us
something we already know yeah we'll say
yeah getting even to do or something
like that
Oh Jay and say that [ __ ] it already
starts like his first thing on Twitter
oh so there was like probably shouldn't
have done that here we go and here we go
so there was a new call of duty modern
warfare game announced and there some
video game journalists that are super
offended by it I quite simply don't
understand I don't get how its this is
this is it you know this is the line
this is the thing that it's like this is
next-level [ __ ] it's a first-person
shooter that's a war game that sounds
like it accurately depicts the tough
choices and the horror and brutality of
those situations so in that the
congratulations guys made a proper war
game that might just feel uncomfortable
[ __ ] hell I I don't get a lot of
Internet outrage
to be honest with you I just don't
understand a lot of it but I don't get
it nor farming we're talking about
shitty reality TV that we watch and
whine and then we were talking about how
these people sometimes there's a little
more boring than you want and she was
like when I sign up for reality TV III
don't want what would you say boring ass
[ __ ] live [ __ ] I was like holy crap
if I write a book that's the title of my
book boring ass [ __ ] life [ __ ] by
Jeremy Jones the Jeremy :
the Jeremy Jones store
but it'll say : Lauren goes [ __ ] live
[ __ ] : spelled out the Jeremy Joseph I
love it so I guess the Joker movies are
rated I guess we found that out today I
guess Todd feels like tweeted it or
something it still has to be good our
writing doesn't mean it's going to be
good but you know so it's a good start
and the grind is done so let's get
everything else
never underestimate my dog's abilities
to just get tangled the [ __ ] up okay so
we got a new treat for danger in gypsy
it looks like a piece of like round beef
jerky which I guess is a dehydrated bull
dick or something what it is right all
right they're going next level with the
outfit because that outfit is from the
movie what that in every way shape and
form is Shang soon from the movie that's
amazing so god bags under my eyes in
this lighting huh it's no better
Lighting's no better here
maybe I'm just beat as tired but heading
off to Vegas and it does feel like I go
to Vegas a lot but it's a good getaway
you know for you and a girlfriend you
and a friend you and a group of friends
you and yourself you and a group of
girlfriends whatever Vegas last night I
was doing my Toy Story 4 spoiler talk
video I still had to pack and do 100
things had a prep it's just I kind of I
feel like I kind of sped through my Toy
Story 4 spoiler talk video so maybe it
didn't go as deep as some people might
want and it will find out in the
comments section it goes live at
midnight tonight but that's just how I
feel about it
I would have liked to have gone deeper
but I just I simply didn't have the time
so sorry for that two shots of pure
goodness yeah Cheers yeah I'm on the
26th floor and as you saw with that
button arrangement it looks like the
26th floor is like above all the others
which I mean
is in terms of height but it just it's
the button standing by itself so it
looks like it's something and everyone's
always like oh the penthouse suite but
it's totally about the penthouse suite
so basically every time I'm in the
elevator and people are like oh how
sweet
I'm forced with a decision whether or
not to actually be honest and tell them
oh no it's not the penthouse patients
top floor it's not penthouse it's just a
room or let them believe it's the
penthouse suite I'm kind of 5050 look if
I can't have a penthouse suite at least
you let people believe you're in one
without you actually ever insinuating
that you were most the time I'm honest
though I'm like nah it's just a room
honest to a fault he's not a bad view
we've only been out for a few minutes
like 109 and we're already burned like
my ears burning
we only blush from one building to the
other it's like next level it's like
that movie the core after the core of
the earth stops spinning and then the
ultraviolet rays pursue
vanessa is looking at me like what the
talk about me crying I'm talking about
great beasts sci-fi movies but damn it
do you really yeah she's burn - no
matter what anyone says that stands for
mortal kombat imma move here I call this
one the phantom pain throughout the pool
at Bellagio actually ruin the jacuzzi I
belong here
and they do have a bar or even order
drinks for 650 bucks for a grand total
including tip of just about 40 bucks so
I think we're going to do fat Tuesday's
tomorrow yeah I'm cheap I'm cheap
whatever yeah so we're here at Bellagio
we're about to see Cirque du Soleil
titled oh I don't know anything about
this cable fella but I guarantee he
hasn't killed as many people's melanoma
house all right as I'm reaching the end
of my Fat Tuesday on the last day
I'm begging that is less intimated I
think this is what we're flying out the
Vegas point is there's a question bring
happiness to people it's really the
answer to all life's questions I don't
think people are asking not enough
people anyway and that question is what
would Jared Harris do he's so goddamn
he's so good
one of the number-one comments I get is
what do I think about Robert Pattinson
as Batman people are baffled that I
haven't said anything about it and the
fact is here's what I think I think he
could be good or he might not be I think
he could suck or I might not be but he
might be good but we'll see and that's
all I have to contribute to it really
with Robert Pattinson what I've seen him
in are the Twilight movies and I think
that's a fair representation of his
ability I've heard he's great in other
things so I might actually just be the
least qualified person to say something
about it I know how people you might be
thinking well you talked about Ben
Affleck being cast as Batman so that
doesn't make any sense but it does
because that was what five years ago so
I think I'm going to take what I learned
from that apply to this and just go
ahead and say simply I'm [ __ ] though
we'll see how he does I'm not gonna lie
to you I just don't feel like watching a
movie or doing a video today um but I'm
back from Vegas and child's play so I
like the theater maybe is what I need
though you know delve into work get my
mind off of [ __ ] here's hoping if
nothing else it'll be distracting or so
since my child's play reviews already
late the timely one who wanted to get up
was for Annabelle comes home so that's
up now so I just got this in the mail
let's start playing some blesse can't
even see it declare what so I uploaded
my review for child's play last night
and for some odd reason YouTube's
keeping the resolution at 360 like it's
a 1080 video 360 though and I thought it
would be better by morning it's not so
that's YouTube that's that's not a I
exported it weird they're like I just
hope it gets worked out before my
spider-man far from home review goes up
tomorrow because that would be really
shitty you know like child's play is one
things oh it's a movie that's a few days
old whatever it's a child's play remake
but wait alright so it's 360 but
spider-man's gotta be 1080p good one so
I wake up this morning with an Instagram
from somebody a fan who said hey if
you're on the wait list for the hot toys
Scarlet Spider you can pre-order it
right now for a limited time so I go on
there sure enough you can and I did and
now I'm gonna get Scarlet Spider so
thank you for doing that more than a few
times
fans have messaged me and been like hey
I know you like to sing so this thing's
available if you want it I'm like oh my
god I wouldn't have known that otherwise
so thank you thank you all for looking
out I really appreciate it that's how I
got my night trap record soundtrack
which is great and it's great to have
and I wouldn't have known about it or at
least like I knew about it but I thought
I totally missed the boat on it know the
guy right I'll never get it now and a
fan sent the link to me and was like hey
you can get them here and they were out
and I guess they got more in I wouldn't
have known that otherwise all right
thank you all for looking at so Adam and
I were hanging out today and found this
for 10 bucks this dangerous scraping at
the curtain to get outside he needs to
piss but the point is danger I need to
tell the people alright so I found this
today for 10 bucks I don't have a system
to play it on so saw like I could play
it I wanted it it's like collectability
of those points those 10 dollars I just
wanted to have it also also bought this
bus fire for 30 again collectability now
like I'm gonna play on my play-doh and
of course the worst segment thus far is
the water level well I I really regret
not getting blood stained ritual of the
night for ps4 I got a purse which
because I've got a switch smells like
which is a great system and it is a
great system but the switch port of that
game no but it's just the latency among
graphical issues
I should just got on ps4 there's part of
it's like I kind of want to drop 40
bucks just to buy the game on ps4 and
just start it from scratch it's split on
that but now I'm already this far in the
game so I might as well just played on
suede she was still regret
all right maniacs that's my June journal
entry thank you all for watching and
there was actually I feel like I might
get a couple comments asking like well
why didn't you touch on this thing that
there was a tragedy in June
I suppose every month has a myriad of
tragedies but there was a youtuber his
name was Etica and he tragically took
his own life and I gave my thoughts on
it and then the contrast between getting
that serious and then going back to the
whimsy of the day-to-day journal entries
it just felt really weird so I just I
cut it out and then I I filmed a couple
things
a couple attempts to talk about it here
at the end and it just felt like I was
going on my own soapbox I will simply
say if you feel like you're lost or in a
corner or in a scenario you don't know
how to get out of if things seem glib or
bleak talk to a professional I'm telling
you from experience therapy is very
helpful it's not like talking to a
friend you know talking to a friend's
good in that hey man you got this put a
band-aid over it kind of way but talking
to a professional is down two years of
school and had years of experience
peeling back the layers and getting to
the root of problems you'll be baffled
at what you will learn about yourself
and I promise you it will get better so
please do that because people care and
they care about you so I guess I'll like
use this moment to say that so thank you
very much for watching my journal
entries thank you for letting me get
serious at the end here for a second and
as always if you liked what you've seen
here and you wanna see more click right
here to see more I love you all
you
[Music]